I mean if you obviously myself I whether
it's my poetry and my spoken-word me on
social media even in interviews I've
been quite outspoken for the past few
years and and to me I'd like to practice
what I preach so I'm in these
communities constantly you know taking
meetings with district attorney's about
you know criminal justice reform and
prison reforming it's so important I
mean again I've been given a the
spotlight so i want to say the proper
things at the proper time so really
instead of doing a lot of talking and a
lot of typing and texting and all that i
like to live it and so I'm kind of
putting my money where my mouth is I'm
putting my efforts where my mouth is and
i'm actually in the community so I know
we're all upset about a lot of things
that are going on and to me instead of
getting out and just just talking about
it I'm really trying to do it in I have
you know great mentors like Harry
Belafonte's and big Craig reading and
people that actually were a part of the
original civil rights movement that
inspire me and guided me to kind of get
out here and be a man of the people and
be a man of the community and I'm making
that dedication and I'm making them a
real way